shipping forecasters in and the seas are
looking choppy a crucial tool to
temperature check the global economy the
industry now looks like it's in the eye
of the storm a key gauge for the sector
sunk to a record low at the end of last
month in fact the cost to ship raw
materials around the world is now more
than 80 percent less than its 31 year
historical daily average analysts point
to two reasons firstly there's a glut of
ships out there they were ordered during
the pre-crisis boom years and many are
still being built the number of capsized
vessels for example the biggest ships
transporting 150,000 tons or more have
doubled since 2008 in fact the world's
Freight fleet is expected to grow more
than four percent this year while demand
for the goods they transport will grow
less than 2 percent and older ships
which would have once been demolished
are being kept in service because the
scrap steel prices are too low all that
extra capacity has crushed freight rates
it's now cheaper in fact to hire an
eleven hundred foot merchant vessel than
rent a Ferrari f40 for the day then
there's China slowing growth meant there
were actually fewer ships importing iron
ore and coal into the country in 2015
compared to the year before the first
time that's happened in at least a
decade looking out onto the horizon many
expect more storms ahead for shipping
and the global economy